Guten Abend.
Karakulak ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Diensthabender auf dieser Station
und würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen,
möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Isabel Frewert.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ja, Isabel schreibt sich I-S-A-B-E-L.
Isabel Frewert, F-R-E-W-E-R-T.
Okay, bravo Frewert.
Wie heißen Sie?
59 Jahre.
49 Jahre.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 16. August 1965.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1 Meter 69.
69.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie zur Zeit?
66 kg.
Okay.
Frewert, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie?
Ich habe so seit ungefähr drei Tagen,
vor drei Tagen ist das angefangen,
da schmerzt mein Rechtes Bein.
Und besonders im Unterschenkel.
Auf der Außenseite am Unterschenkel.
Und das geht bis in den Seitenfuß.
Hauptsächlich im Unterschenkel.
Könnten Sie Ihre Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie stechendrückend oder dumpf?
Die sind mehr so dumpf.
Bohrend.
Also ob jemand ein Gummi-Band nimmt
und dieses Gummi-Band um die Wade spannt.
Eine Spannung?
Ja, kann man sagen.
Ich habe auch noch etwas Rückenschmerzen,
aber ich denke es ist nicht so stark.
Die Hauptsäge sind bein.
Und wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen
auf eine Schmerzkala, wobei 1,
sehr leichte und 10 sehr starker Schmerzen bedeutet?
Ich würde sagen 6.
Soll ich Ihnen etwas geben?
Also gegen Schmerzen?
Nein, nein, nein, müssen Sie nicht.
Ich habe gestern mal 2 Tabletten Evo-Profen genommen,
aber das hat nichts geholfen.
Okay, wie viel Milgramm?
Ich glaube 600 stand dahinter.
Okay, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Okay.
Und vorwärts.
Also Außenseite und Taschenkel, meinen Sie?
Ja, das geht bis in den Fuß,
bis in den kleinen Zee,
auf die Seite vom Kleid vom Fuß.
Okay. Und haben Sie Unfall?
Ein Unfall hatte ich nicht, gestürzt bin ich auch nicht.
Okay.
Und feststellen Sie die Schmerzen im Verlauf?
Also wenn ich mich bewege so,
wenn ich mich umdrehen möchte,
so im Bett oder wenn ich huste,
ich muss oft husten wegen meiner Bronchitis,
das tut dann mehr weh noch.
Dann schießt das so richtig ins Bein runter.
Ach, verstehe. Also, wow,
gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindern?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Wenn ich mich ganz ruhig hinlege
etwas anziehe zum Körper,
dann ist es vielleicht etwas besser,
aber ein gewisser Schmerz ist immer da.
Okay. Und im betroffenen Bereich
haben Sie eine second
stichend bemerkt?
Eckenstich? Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay. Gibt es im betroffenen Bereich,
also ist die betroffenen Bereich
etwas rötend oder geschwollend?
Also ich meine,
dass die Haut auf dem Bein etwas heller ist,
etwas blasser ist, die Haut.
Und wenn ich so rüberfahre über die Haut,
dann fühlt sie sich auch teilweise etwas taub an.
Und kühler.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und Sie haben schon, wenn es haupeist,
etwas kribbeln? Ja, so ein bisschen kribbeln.
Wie Ameisen laufen so?
Und wie weit können Sie laufen?
Ja, das ist noch etwas anders.
Mit dem Laufen. Seit einigen Wochen habe ich bemerkt,
dass ich nicht mehr so lange laufen kann.
Ich muss dann so nach ungefähr, weiß ich nicht,
200 Metern, 150 Metern anhalten
und dann kann ich wieder weitergehen.
Aber das ist irgendwie anders als jetzt diese Schmerzen,
die ich jetzt seit 3 Tagen habe.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie das bemerkt?
Ja, ich würde sagen seit vielleicht 4, 5 Wochen.
4, 5 Wochen, okay.
Ja, und Sie müssen Pause machen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also jetzt habe ich einige Fragen zu Ihnen,
allgemein zu stattfragen.
Ist Ihnen übel oder war Ihnen übel? Nein.
Nein? Okay.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe mein Gewicht immer gehalten.
Okay.
Und haben Sie einen Herstupfen oder Herstbasen bemerkt?
Nein.
Nein? Ich habe mich nicht.
Okay.
Und ist Ihr Bein geschwollen?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass das geschwollen ist.
Nee, sieht nicht so aus.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, Wasserlassen hat sich nicht verändert.
Stuhlgang auch nicht.
Ich muss nachts ein bis zweimal auf Toilette Wasser lassen,
aber das schon seit 1, 2 Mal.
Das hängt immer davon ab, was ich abends zu trinke.
Aber ich kann danach immer gut einschlafen.
Ach super, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit? Haben Sie Appetitlosigkeit?
Nein, mein Appetit ist gut.
Okay, super.
Und jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihnen,
Krankengeschichte, Vollgeschichte, Frau Färbert.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie ein
Bronchitis haben seit 1?
Ja, ich habe so seit ungefähr 4 Jahren.
Da war ich auch einmal beim Lungenfacharzt
und er hat gesagt, das ist eine chronische Bronchitis,
wahrscheinlich durch mein Rauchen.
Das wird oft im Herbst und Winter schlechter.
Da muss ich auch manchmal,
letzten Winter muss ich zweimal Antibiotika nehmen.
Da hatte ich auch Fieber, aber das war im letzten Winter.
Ich musste auch Medikamente immer einnehmen.
Muss ich ein inhalieren und Spreis nehmen.
Okay, was für Medikamente dann?
Da nehme ich einmal Sultanul, Sultanul-Sprei.
Das Mittel, da vergesse ich den Namen immer.
Das heißt, wieani.
Wieani, wie schreibt man das?
Ich habe hier so ein Zettel.
V-I-A-N-G.
I-A-N-I, wieani.
Ja, das sind so Kapseln, die muss ich jetzt an Apparat tun.
Da muss ich drauf drücken, dann kommt ein Staub raus.
Da muss ich einhalten.
Zweimal am Tag.
Sultanul-Sprei auch?
Ja, auch zweimal am Tag, im Winter manchmal auch dreimal.
Winter dreimal, okay.
Jetzt, außer Bronchitis,
sind bei Ihnen ökologische Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, ich habe noch hohen Blutdruck.
Er ist auch so seit 4 oder 5 Jahren bekannt.
Da nehme ich auch ein Medikament.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie an?
Kandi-Satan heißt, dahinter steht 16.
Da nehme ich eine morgens und eine halbe zur Nacht.
Okay.
Ja, gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe noch seit 2 Jahren festgestellt,
da hatte ich einen Bruch, da bin ich gestürzt.
Da habe ich mir die Älle und die Speiche gebrochen.
Am linken Unterarm.
Das musste operiert werden.
Da hat man festgestellt, dass ich eine schwere Osteoporose habe.
Okay, Osteoporose.
Es ist Speiche und welche Knurren haben Sie?
Und Älle.
Da muss ich auch Medikamente nehmen.
Das war vor 2 Jahren, oder?
Ja, vor gut 2 Jahren war das.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente gegen Osteoporose?
Ja, ich muss einmal in der Woche eine Tablette nehmen.
Danach darf ich mich nicht hinlegen.
Die heißt Allendronsäure.
Okay, Allendronsäure.
Und dann nehme ich noch einmal am Tag Vitamin D.
Dahinter steht 1000.
1000, okay.
Und gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, nicht.
Sie haben schon eventuell unterarm gebrochen.
Vor 2 Jahren.
Wie wurde diese Knurren gebrochen?
Er wurde eine Platte rangeht.
Die war jetzt und mit Schrauben behandelt.
Und gibt es noch Operationen?
Ja, als Kind.
Da war ich so 10 Jahre alt.
Da wurde ich am Blindarm operiert.
Und vor 4 Jahren war das, glaube ich,
da wurde ich am linken Knie oder eine Spiegelung gemacht.
Und da wurde der Meniscus behandelt.
Der war eingerissen.
Und da wurde ein Teil des Meniscus entfernt.
Und das hat gut geholfen.
Ich habe seitdem beim Knie eigentlich keine großen Beschwerden mehr.
Okay, super.
Gibt es noch, dass ich wissen sollte?
Nein, sonst keine Operationen mehr.
Außer die Medikamente, die Sie schon erwähnt haben.
Gibt es noch andere Medikamente, die Sie?
Nein, nehm ich keinen anderen.
Sind bei Ihnen Allegien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Nein, ich vertrage alles.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie rauchen?
Wie viel Zeit rauchen Sie täglich?
Ja, das ist natürlich mein Laster.
Ich rauche so 20 Zigaretten am Tag.
Schon ungefähr 35 Jahre lang.
Ich bin nur immer pausiert bei den beiden Schwangerschaften.
Da habe ich eine Pause gemacht.
Das ging auch, aber danach ging es nicht.
Ich habe auch schon versucht aufzuhören.
Aber das habe ich bisher nicht geschafft.
Aber wenn Sie wollen, nach dem Gespräch, können wir darüber sprechen.
Wir haben eine gute Beratungsstelle.
Können wir dann machen, ja.
Und zinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends so zum Abendessen ein Glas Wein.
Ein kleines Glas Wein, 0,1.
0,1.
Okay.
Seit wann?
Das mache ich jetzt schon einige Jahre.
Sagen wir jetzt mindestens 30 Jahre.
20 Jahre, okay.
Die nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Frau Färbert, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Und waren Sie in Neste sei im Ausland?
Ich war vor, wann war das?
Im März war ich im Gran Canaria.
Gran Canaria, in Riffa oder wo Gran Canaria war das.
Da war ich 10 Tage im Urlaub.
Und sonst war ich in Deutschland im Urlaub, an der Ostsee.
Okay, ja.
Und wie ist Ihre Impfstatus, Frau Färbert?
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ich bekomme jetzt meine fünfte Covid-Impfung.
Da hat meine Hausärztin gesagt,
das wäre wichtig wegen meiner Bronchitis auch.
Und ich bekomme jetzt Covid-Impfung und Grippe-Impfung.
Das sollte jetzt in den nächsten 14 Tagen sein.
Okay, okay.
Frau Färbert, besuchen Sie Ihre Frauen erst regelmäßig?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
Wann war die letzte Vorsorgeuntersuchung?
Im April.
Und jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familiengeschichte.
Frau Färbert, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die Mutter leben noch.
Sie haben sich in der Familie geholfen.
Wie leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Die Mutter lebt noch. Die Mutter ist 84 Jahre alt.
Die hat Alterszucker und hat auch Osteoporose.
Und der Vater ist mit 76 Jahren verstorben.
Am Lungenkrebs.
Und der hatte auch lange so Bronchitis
und hatte dann auch in den letzten Jahren vor seinem Tod
so Blutgefäßverengung in den Beinen.
Und der Vater ist mit 76 Jahren verstorben.
Und da konnte er auch kaum mehr gehen.
Und er ging dann viel am Rollator und zuletzt im Rollstuhl.
Okay, my bylight,
Frau Färbert,
Ihr heißt Frau Färbert?
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Und was machen Sie bei der Ufling, Frau Färbert?
In Sekretärin bei einem Rechtsanwalt.
Sekretärin bei Rechtsanwalt.
Okay, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein, die Arbeit ist angenehm.
Das ist das mit dich.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Und wir haben zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, die sind gesund.
Die sind 28 und 30 Jahre alt.
Die wohnen aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Jetzt möchte ich auf Ihre Beschwerden zurückkommen.
Frau Färbert, waren Sie schon mal wegen dieser Beschwerden
beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, war ich noch nicht.
Wegen dieser Beingeschichte mit dem Gen
und dass ich dann stehen bleiben muss,
das wollte ich der Hausärztin jetzt sagen,
bei der Grippeimpfung.
Okay, und wann war Ihr letzter Radiologeuntersuchung?
Waren Sie?
Nein, ich war noch nie.
Aber ich hatte vor drei oder vier Jahren
Rückenschmerzen
und auch so Ischias-Schmerzen ins Bein rein.
Der Orthopäde, das wäre ein Ischias.
Das war vor drei Jahren auf den rechten Beinen.
Da habe ich dann Spritzen bekommen,
fünf Stück.
Und auch Krankengymnastik.
Und danach war das eigentlich recht gut.
Okay, okay, Frau Färbert.
Also von meiner Seite habe ich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Frau Färbert, fällt Ihnen etwas ein,
das ich wissen sollte oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, was habe ich? Was kann das sein?
Also Frau Färbert, Ihre Beschwerden deuten auf eine
Verschluss im Gefäße,
im Beingefäße.
Ja, aber das ist zuzeit eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Und wir, diese Diagnose zu bestätigen,
sollen wir einige Untersuchungen durchführen,
wie körperliche Untersuchungen, Labor-Untersuchungen
und gegebenenfalls eine feineutere Scheile.
Okay.
Sobald alle befundervoll sind, kann ich Ihnen genau sagen,
was Ihnen fehlt.
Okay, das ist gut.
Das können wir so machen.
Gut, dann haben Sie jetzt wieder die berühmten,
weniger als 20 Minuten Zeit.
Ja, 16 Minuten.
Sie haben in der Diagnose sehr zügig gemacht.
Ich habe mir Elks auf die Uhr geschaut, das waren jetzt
ein bisschen über 17 Minuten, sehr gut.
Bleiben, dass Sie in dem Zeitfenster bleiben von 20 Minuten.
Ja, ist gut.
Ich habe Fragen von Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Ja.
Gibt es in Ihrem Betroffenen mein Wunder?
Nein, eine Wunder habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Und gibt es eine Muskelschwäche
in Ihrem Fuß oder unter Schenkel?
Sie meinen, dass ich da nicht so richtig Kraft habe,
oder so?
Ja, genau. Kraft bei Lust.
Ja, ich kann ja durch die Schmerzen nicht so gut gehen.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck,
wenn ich mit dem rechten Bein auftrete,
das ist nicht so sicher.
Vielleicht ist es etwas schwächer.
Das kann sein. Aber ich habe eben so starke Schmerzen.
Deswegen traue ich mich nicht, mich groß zu bewegen.
Okay, danke.
Ich habe keine Fragen gestattet, Herr Oberast.
Aber unser Kollegen hat gefragt,
per Kardi und ödem,
aber muss ich Dispne fragen,
wie viel Kissen benötigt sich zum Beispiel?
Ja, kann man natürlich fragen,
oder ob die Beine sonst mal anschwellen.
Frau Friebert hat keine großen Beschwerden.
Sie schläft mit einem Kissen.
Ja, das ist eine sehr große Frage.
Die Beine sind auch abends besonders nicht geschwollen.
Wir haben hier ja eigentlich
zwei sich überlagende Schmerzbilder.
Diesen Fall sollte ja ein etwas schwierigerer Fall sein.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
drei Tage angefangen, aber der Patient hat nicht gesagt,
wirst du schon da,
oder du hast es nicht gesagt,
du wirst es nicht,
aber der Patient hat nicht gesagt,
wirst du schon da, langsam angefangen?
Also das ging relativ, das baute sich sehr schnell auf.
Es war aber nicht ganz plötzlich.
Es fing an, aber es ging dann sehr schnell,
dass es stärker wurde.
Dieser Schmerz ist eben mehr im Bein als im Rücken.
Es ist im Latte,
im seitlichen Unterschenkel, sage ich jetzt bewusst so,
dass es sich in den Fuß aus verstärkt sich beim Husten.
Es gibt so ein Ribbelgefühl im Bein.
Beim Drüberfühlen
ist die Haut fühlt sich anders an.
Beim linken Bein gibt es einen Unterschied.
Die Patientin hat eben gesagt,
dass sie seit einigen Wochen eben diese Schmerzen im Bein hat.
Wenn sie einen Schmerz im Bein hat,
dann hat die Patientin eben gesagt,
dass sie einen Schmerzen im Bein hat,
wenn sie eine Strecke geht,
dass sie dann stehen bleiben muss.
Das war rundet,
das war rundet 50.
Ja.
Wie können wir als erstes gespräch anfangen?
Ja, es gibt viele Informationen,
aber dann versuche ich mal.
Ich weiß, dass ich nie anfangen kann.
Schönen guten Abend, Herr Obatz.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen,
die ich Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Sie heißt Isabel Fröwert.
Sie ist 55,
59 Jahre alt,
1 Meter 69 groß
und 66 Kilogramm schwer.
Sie hat bei uns seit 3 Tagen
bestehende
dünnfer, bohrende
unter Schenkelschmerzen
in der Lateralsite
vollgestellt.
Die Schmerzen legen auf
einer Schmerzskala bei 8 von 10
und
beim Bewegung
und Hüsten
und Umdrehen verschlägt sich die Schmerzen
und
beim Ruhre
und Hinsätze
versät sich die Schmerzen.
Außerdem beschreibt der Patient
dass sie auch
Taubweisgefühl
Phypostesie, Parästhesie
und
Parasie im Betroffenen
Bein haben
und
haben im gesamten Bein oder
in bestimmten Regionen des Beines.
Also der Lateralsite
der Seite des Fußes und bis
bis Finger.
Ich habe das so richtig verstanden, dass sie sagen
die Patientin hat seit 3 Tagen
eher zunehmende
Schmerzen
in den Bein, ganz überwiegend, besonders
im Bereich des rechten
Lateralen unter Schenkels.
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, und Schmerzen strahlen bis in den Fuß
kleinzehenseitig ein.
Ja, genau.
Es bestehen darüber hinaus Krippelparästhesien
und Parasie
Ich muss die
Phypostesie geben oder nicht?
Ich denke nicht.
Ja, Parästhesie
keine Parästhesie.
Ja, Kraftverlust, ein subjektiver, aber direkter Parästhesie.
Gut, das müsste dann die körperliche Untersuchung vielleicht nicht sein.
Ja, vielleicht.
Hat die Patientin solche Beschwerden
schon einmal gehabt?
Ja, schon einmal.
Sie hat gefragt, aber seit 4 bis 5 Wochen
hat der Patient
eine Kradikation-Internetanz.
Sie beschreibt, also
nach 250 Metern
muss der Patient eine Pause machen.
Okay.
Die Patientin darüber hinaus beschreibt,
dass die Patientin seit einigen Wochen
bestehende belastungsabhängige
Beinschmerz, auch im rechten Bein
im Sinne, kann man ruhig sagen,
eine Aclaudicatio-Internetanz.
Das ist der zweite Themenkomplex.
Hat die Patientin Rückenschmerzen?
Ja, also die Patient beschritt eine Rückenschmerz.
Und das war auch 2, 3, 4
Monaten oder?
Jahre.
Ja, Jahre.
War der Patient beim Otebäden
und wegen dieser Rückenschmerzen.
Damals hat der Arzt
ja gesagt, das kann auch
Ischia-Gi sein.
Ja, also die Patientin hat glaube ich berichtet,
keine Rückenschmerzen, sondern auch Beinschmerzen.
Beinschmerzen auch.
Das war eine Lumbo-Ichia-Gi.
Also Schmerzen, die ins Bein,
ins Segment des Beines ausstrahlen.
Keine reiner Rückenschmerzen.
Also außer
die Nygdorie
ist die vegetative Annesis unauffällig.
Also die neurologische Auffälligkeiten
in der Kontinenz?
Also sie hat erwähnt,
dass sie, wenn sie
viel Flüssigkeit
nehmen, also trinken oder nehmen,
dann musste sie Wasser lassen.
Also im Sinne...
Genau, es gibt auch nicht
die Anfälligkeiten
bei Stuhlkank und Miktion.
Ja, im Sinne von Blasen.
Das fängt der Störung, oder so.
Also Anfrollerkrankungen.
Erkrankungen leidet die Patientin
an COPD seit 4 Jahren.
Also zweimal im Jahr
mit antibiotische Therapie behandelt wurden.
Sie neigt im Winter zu Ex-Azurbationen.
Ex-Azurbationen.
Der COPD, die dann oft
antibiotikerpflichtig sind.
Ja.
Außerdem leidet die Patientin an Arteelehytaturnie
seit 4 bis 5 Jahren.
Seit 2 Jahren
wurde bei der Patientin ein Austropos
die Diagnostisiert.
Und dagegen
nehmen die Patientin Soltanausepres
zweimal und Vianicapsules
zweimal. Aber im Winter
soll die Patientin 3 mal
einnehmen.
Soltanol, ja, Vianicapsules Soltanol.
Ja, Soltanol, ja.
Und dann auf den Ort zurück
nehmen die Patientin Candidatan 6
in Arteelehytaturnie.
Ja, Arteelehytaturnie, 16 mg einmal morgens
und halbe am Abend.
Okay.
Und gegen Austropose
nehmen die Patientin
alle Drohnsäure
mit Vitamin D 1000 mg einmal
täglich.
Gibt es Operationen bei der Patientin?
Ja, also vor 2 Jahren
wurde der Patient wegen
Unna- und Radiusfraktur operiert.
Also mit Platten und Schrauben
und Austrosentässe
wurde gemacht.
Und die Patientin
hat mit Alter von 10 Jahren
wurde der Patient
die Patientin
eine Appendectomie
appendectomiert.
Und vor 4 Jahren
wegen Menisküs-Risse
wurde der Patient
bei der Patientin
erfolgt er vor 2 Jahren
oder vor 4 Jahren eine
Atroskopische
Meniskus-Teilresektion.
Atroskopisch.
Gut, gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der
Familienanamnese?
Ja, also der Vater
ist wegen
Bronchalkarsinom gestorben
und
wie alt war er?
74.
Und bei der Vater
hat er auch
an
Blutgefäss-Verwendung
eine
Perfektion.
Also auch hat der Vater
soopi gelitten.
Ja, okay.
Die Mutter ist 84 Jahre alt
und leider
an Diabetes meleutus Typ 1
und leider an auch Osteoporose.
Und sie ist
Sekretärin vom Beruf.
Wir heiraten und haben 2 gesunde Kinder.
Aufgrund der ananistischen Angaben
gehe ich von auch...
Gibt es noch kurze Frage?
Ja, also sie ist Raucherin.
Sie, der
den Nekotinkonsum beträgt 35 Pakungsjahr.
Ja, okay.
Und der Alkoholkonsum beträgt
Einglaswein täglich seit 20 Jahren.
Okay.
Sie ist vorständig geübt.
Prima. Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist
PAVK.
Die finanziellen Diagnostik kommen auch
Isiagi
und
vielleicht
also
was zu sagen,
ein, den, noch.
Also ich denke, Sie haben die beiden wesentlichen
Erkrankungen oder Verdachtdiagnosen genannt.
Ja.
Ich würde sagen, der Schmerz, weshalb
Frau Rehwardt Akut kommt, der seit 3 Tagen besteht.
Ja. Okay, dann.
Das ist mehr im Sinne einer Lumboisiagi,
im Sinne eines Diskusprolapses.
Wahrscheinlich im Segment 115.
Lateraler Unterschenkel,
Sensibilitätsstörung und bis in den kleinen,
also kleinen Zähnbereich einstrahlen.
Wir haben die Segmenten L5S1,
der hauptsächlich im Unterschenkelbereich.
Die anderen sind mehr oberhalb, L4, L3.
Dafür spricht der Hustenschmerz,
die Sensibilitätsstörung,
die Parästhesien,
die etwas kühlere Haut kommt
vielleicht bei der nächsten Diagnose dann damit rein.
Aber der akute Schmerz, glaube ich, die die Patientin
jetzt hat, ist wahrscheinlich ein Diskusprolaps
oder ein zumindest eine Lumboisiagi.
Was kann auch wegen Oste vor seine Knochenbruch, also ...
Kann theoretisch auch sein,
nur dieser ausstrahlende Schmerz,
die hat ja auch Rückenschmerzen.
Sie hat ja auch Rückenschmerzen.
Sie könnten differenzieren, Sie könnten sagen,
wie stark sind denn Ihre Rückenschmerzen gegenüber zum Beinschmerz?
Das ist ein wichtiges diagnostisches Kriterium.
Wie Schmerz-Jerapeuten sagen oft,
wenn der Rückenschmerz überwiegt und der Beinschmerz eher nicht,
dann ist ein Diskusprolaps nicht unbedingt sehr wahrscheinlich,
aber ein starker Beinschmerz.
Stärker als der Rückenschmerz, der Lumbalschmerz,
ist auf ein Diskusprolaps.
Also verdacht auf Diskusprolaps
mit mäßiger Neurologie,
wohl keine Paresen mit dem Kraftgrad war nicht so klar bisher,
weil die Patientin sich nicht gut bewegen kann.
Aber als zweite Diagnose kommt sicherlich die
PAVK ins Spiel.
Deswegen war das jetzt ein bisschen schwierigerer Fall,
der sich so überlagert.
Zwei verschiedene Ursachen.
Diskusprolaps war gut und die PAVK,
die sich schon seit Wochen aufgebaut hat
aufgrund ihrer Risikofaktoren, sprich,
Nikotinabusus, die familiäre Vorbelastung,
der Vater hatte eine PAVK und so weiter.
Das würde ich so sagen.
Die Claudicazio-Intermittenz,
wie sie das schildert,
typischerweise 150 Meter, 200 Meter.
Jetzt kommt noch dieser Ischias dazu.
Das war jetzt etwas schwierig,
aber sie haben sich da ganz gut.
Und wenn sie als erstes die PAVK nennen,
ist das ja auch nicht schlimm.
Da ist es vielleicht sogar wichtiger,
dass da im Gefäß genau geschaut wird,
ist es vielleicht schon ein Verschluss oder ein Drohenderverschluss
dass man da vielleicht
dementsprechend interveniert,
um das Gefäß wieder aufzubekommen.
Diskusprolaps scheint mir jetzt nicht so gravieren zu sein.
Es gibt keine Caudersymptomatik,
Blasen, Mastarmen ist offenkundig intakt.
Von daher gesehen würde ich mich als erstes
wahrscheinlich auf die Gefäße konzentrieren.
Anschließend aber die Bandscheibe nicht vergessen.
Wenn ich das jetzt mal aufhörte,
dann werde ich das nicht vergessen.
Und wenn Sie die Patientin klinisch untersuchen,
dann werden Sie wahrscheinlich eine Reflexdifferenz feststellen.
Wenn Sie sie neurologisch untersuchen.
Und Sie werden gleichzeitig wahrscheinlich feststellen,
dass vielleicht Ihr Arteriator Dorsalis pedis
oder Tbalis posterior,
oder was auch immer schwach oder nicht nachweisbar sind.
Und dann müssen Sie halt dementsprechend handeln.
Und dann können Sie die Besuchung sagen.
Ja, damit könnte man die Diagnosen schon sehr gut eingrenzen.
Ja, gut.
Ja, aber ich finde, das haben Sie gut gelöst und gut gemacht.
Ich habe Sie sehr gut verstanden.
Und Sie haben auch die wesentlichen Fachbegriffe gebracht.
Zwischendurch den Bluthochdruck genannt.
Da wissen Sie, dass das die arterielle Hypertonie ist.
Aber das ist alles kein Problem.
Und ich denke, Sie sind gut vorbereitet.
Können wir Bandscheiben vorfallen?
Ich würde sagen, es besteht wahrscheinlich
ein Verdacht auf Discos prolapse.
Ja, würde ich ruhig schreiben.
Verdacht auf Lumbuishaldi oder Wurzelreizyndrom.
L5, wahrscheinlich L5.
Und dann muss man weiter natürlich diagnostizieren.
Da wird ein CT wahrscheinlich geprägt.
Der Wirbelsäule.
Aber vorrangig würde ich sagen,
lieber die Gefäße erst angucken.
Um zu gucken, ist etwas zu rekanalisieren.
Interventionell.
Spinalkanal stenose.
Das heißt Spinalkanal stenose.
Kann es auch sein, aber die hat glaube ich ein bisschen andere Klinik.
Aber das werden Sie ja bis jetzt sehen,
wenn Sie die LWS eine Bildgebung machen.
Aber vorrangig denke ich, um das Gefäß, das Bein zu erhalten.
Nicht, dass das Bein gefährdet ist.
Von wegen Gefäßverschluss.
Ich glaube ich als erstes, was macht man heutzutage?
Ne MR, Angio oder so etwas?
Ja, danke.